for the first time President Biden
himself is explaining the decision to
shoot down four flying objects this
month the president spoke after repeated
demands from Republicans for more
information Ed O'Keefe is at the White
House Ed good morning good morning may
President Biden says the intelligence
Community has determined that those
three objects probably weren't a threat
just for research or weather monitoring
but after the shoot down she's now
asking for new protocols to help
distinguish between unmanned objects
that are a threat and those that aren't
I gave the order to take down these
three objects President Biden telling
the public Thursday what he knows and
still doesn't know about the objects
that were up there and ordered shot down
nothing nothing right now suggests they
were related to China's spy balloon
program the unknown objects may not have
ties to China but officials say that
large balloon that traveled across the
U.S before being shot down off South
Carolina's Coast definitely did they
just shot it and the President says he
plans to bring it up with China's leader
I expect to be speaking with President
XI CBS News has learned the Spy balloon
was first detected in late January after
launching off the south coast of China
U.S intelligence officials believe its
intended course was just over Guam and
Hawaii but winds blew it towards Alaska
across Canada and the continental U.S
before it drifted off the east coast we
shot it down sending a clear message
clear message the violation of our
sovereignty is unacceptable Navy and FBI
dive teams recovered the majority of the
Chinese balloon debris but U.S and
Canadian authorities are still trying to
track down what Remains the other three
objects which were detected with
recently expanded radar sensors there
are hundreds of these cases being
reported we don't do a good job of
monitoring we don't have a systemized
way to respond to it to address that the
president laid out future protocol
including establishing an updated
inventory of these Airborne objects
putting measures in place to improve
detection and updating rules that helped
better distinguish between objects that
pose a risk and those that don't but
make no mistake
if any object presents a threat to the
safety security of the American people I
will take it down
now it's not clear when President Biden
might speak with Chinese president XI
but overnight the Chinese responded by
to all of this by saying that the U.S
needs to work to bring back sound and
steady relations Nate Ed if you're a man
of any age getting a physical is a big
deal and we heard that the president had
his physical yesterday what did we learn
he sure did big deal for any guy but in
this case it's important of course
because he is the oldest U.S president
ever and he's made clear that his health
is a factor and whether or not he'll
mount a re-election campaign in this
case the physicians at Walter Reed
Medical Center say that he is in good
shape remains a healthy and vigorous 80
year old fit to serve they point out of
course that he had covid last year but
has no symptoms of long covid he also
had a lesion removed from his chest
that's being sent for a biopsy
healthy and vigorous is how it would
describe you and handsome by the way
well thank you thank you too Nate